it's called operation Thunderbolt it's
one of the boldest most audacious
missions ever attempted the plan has
three critical stages each man plays a
critical role stage 1 the journey they
must get a unit of commandos to Entebbe
this is the task of pilot Josh Shani
Shani will lead a convoy of four
Hercules c-130 transporter planes on a
2,500 mile route to Uganda
[Music]
Entebbe Airport consists of two
terminals the hostages have been held at
the old terminal to the east 2.4
kilometers to the west is the new term
the plan is for the for Hercules to use
the cover of night to land undetected on
this runway
sharni must land first the other three
Hercules will touch down seven minutes
later with backup and supplies Shani has
been warned that the runway lights will
most likely be off in other words he
must land virtually blind this manoeuvre
isn't in the handbook now can you
imagine that if the terrorists will be
alert they can start shooting they can
kill everybody in five minutes Stage two
the transfer once the lead Hercules
lands 30 commandos must get to the doors
of the terminal in total secrecy it's a
two kilometer journey
[Music]
over 100 Ugandan soldiers stand guard on
the tarmac outside the terminal and on
the control tower
mookie betts ax comes up with an
outrageous idea they plan to get from
the Hercules to the terminal by posing
as a Ugandan military escort
betsa recalls how a mean and his army
chiefs are driven about in large black
cars pursued by military jeeps Ugandan
soldiers live in terror of our mean and
his generals when they see such an
escort they let it pass unchallenged the
Israelis are bringing up black Mercedes
and two jeeps to Entebbe incredibly they
plan to drive them straight past the
Ugandan all the way to determine stage
three the assault yoni Netanyahu and a
small force will take on the Ugandan
outside on the tarmac meanwhile teams of
three will storm through the terminal
doors eliminate the terrorists and free
the hostages the next day in total
secrecy the army builds a life-sized
replica of the terminal they handpick
commandos for the mission who rehearse
the assault over and over they must get
every tiny detail right because one
mistake could trigger it to tast Rafi
Defense Minister Perez immediately backs
the plan but it's so risky and
unorthodox that he must persuade many
members of the cabinet officials fail
mama dear for yours